[Music]
and blackout murder news as dark
submitted by I love JK so much thank you
aspiring pastor told the 9-1-1 operator
he took too much cold medicine and found
his wife dead he took too much cold
medicine and found his wife dead he
killed his wife that's weird that's
weird
inspiring that the death in the in the
medicine have anything past her I don't
know it's just a paint a picture of who
this man is
yeah the curly-haired man killed you he
did something like unpassed early that's
why they emphasized the past earnest so
Matthew James felt the same way he's
from North Carolina
he's a 27 year old man he woke up one
night and called 9-1-1 and said that he
took too much cold medicine and that
there was blood all over him and that
there's a bloody knife on the bed he
says that he thinks he did it because he
found his wife doesn't know because he
took a little bit of too much cold
medicine yeah because I [ __ ] me up is
that Cody
it was core chorus sidon course didn't
cough and cold medicine I never heard of
that [ __ ] you should've got the name
Brad stuff bro yeah no idea
I remember hearing it in high school
like oh yeah we got some triple CT I'm
like what the hell is that and they're
like cough medicine
let that leave is Celine shoots at we
this is frigging 10 years ago
oh you opened from what I've heard I
don't know anything even if it was Lena
he would not be able to do that right it
would mean about leanness is our problem
as I handed up saying that he took that
much cuz he heard that this medicine
makes him feel good when he takes it
that's why I remember like oh that
trouble seat so anyway this is what the
couple look looks like she was 29 year
old girl and she was heavily dedicated
in her church she would teach Sunday
school to kids her smile is intense yeah
she got good teeth
oh yeah all top teeth to Colgate why
I'm gonna play show you guys a little
clip of her oh no this is gonna make it
10 times more so man I know this is two
weeks before she died oh wow
pumping up the history buddy these are
available for purchase to everybody
starting September 1st this Isis wife
two weeks earlier in a Facebook live
video about resistant products she was
selling directly to your house so you
can have it
two weeks before anybody else know do
you think he did it but then he's trying
to cover it up like I was under the
influence of robitussin I can kind of
empathize in sleepwalking because I've
taken ambien before and I'll like one of
my most favorite things to do because I
was prescribing anything because I
couldn't sleep one of my favorite things
to do is to wake up the next morning see
what the [ __ ] I did last night my
glasses are in the kitchen shits all
over the floor that's why I say if you
take it you have to go to sleep don't
force yourself to stay awake so I kind
of empathize but on the other hand I've
also never murdered anyone how come
after years and years of technological
growth [ __ ] cop recordings are still
muffling a spot yeah what about that
[ __ ] that's the real crime not and
printers how can printers aren't [ __ ]
good printers still jamming [ __ ] you
know well laser printers are fantastic
oh he looks surprised yeah I feel bad
for her imagine what that must have been
a nightmare man
actually just started up her business -
yeah and your husband is like all of a
sudden trying to stab you shengcún you
know circumstances like have there been
arguing fighting with the lightsabers
we didn't do it on purpose to nurse
don't kill each other like that but you
don't know there might be a dark side to
he might be [ __ ] Sith Lord inside you
don't know he go to jail he's in jail
yes yes for how long he's getting he
can't go there's no bail and he's being
charged one counts of murder I don't
know how to feel about this because he's
sad this is really sad he said I think
though there's just every Prince on the
on the weapons was likely that he was
drugged like date rape drug and they set
everything up that's why I'm wealthy now
the media what they're doing is they're
they're trying test of medicine no so
what their media is doing is they go
they went into his Instagram page and
his tumblr page and they're just
pointing little things out saying that
he had a double life and he's like a
different person on his social media
account so on his stupid he called
himself Marty radical and he had a lot
of photos of him dressed in black which
I don't even know it doesn't mean [ __ ]
does that mean exactly this is what the
media saying and then so he was a
part-time part-time ninja yeah captain
one of one of his photos with the lyrics
by the heavy metal band Korn let's say
quote I can't get out of bed there is
evil in my head just let me be and so
now the media is he denied employee oh
they chose me I just sounds like some
email 13 year old kid yeah yeah and then
on his tumblr page apparently he would
talk about his strange sleeping patterns
saying quote ever since I was little
I've had some strong activity with my
dreams nightmares night terrors
sleepwalking hallucinations and
controlled dreams have filled my life so
far he's a [ __ ] a Fight Club guy
multiple personality it's kind of dirty
and split but if that's true
he can be he might be able to get away
with the sanity mental yes a bargain
yeah like can you imagine yeah you
killed your own life but you didn't want
to but the other half of you did it and
you're inside your brain and you're
[ __ ] Street Fighter in it inside with
them you're gonna find him that that
just just looking fresh yeah you gotta
beat him out of you mmm-hmm very sad
that's why it's shitty like I couldn't
mess with him but I kind of feel like he
could have planned this all out or he
really is suffering but why would
anybody want to kill her though like
she's not like that you know like a
royal princess every man every woman is
a man that's sick for [ __ ] oh yeah I
didn't think of it that way like like
there was an assassin that planned this
[ __ ] out because like but then I wait
but then why is she high profile target
I know why why she's a very successful
candle company and he wanted to take wax
and things to another level and she said
no [ __ ] off medicine or [ __ ] them nor
loopy the most logical explanation that
could come up with okay i'ma use science
so this is what happened he was
possessed by the devil because the devil
day of why and be the devil they don't
want him to be a pastor so he was
holding that [ __ ] back he was
caught blocking his religion so he
entered that soul said uh-uh position
killed the wife BAM that's what happened
magic magic science I want to know how
their relationship was doing like if
they yeah the neighbors like they've
been happy they [ __ ] plant sunflowers
in the backyard every [ __ ] day oh
that's awkward I know but I'm like
they're all happy that's not a real
relationship no keeping a plant why
nobody I bet you your neighbor will be
like yes sometimes they [ __ ] they're
loud they fight some
times you know it's like that's cool
it's always those relationships I would
have never expected they're so awesome
I'm so happy together but if you had
like the neighbors like yeah we heard
them screaming for like the last three
days and things crashing and throwing
that's just a Korean households oh
that's just creepy people all the time
do hymns together
that's a Sunday at the soul house come
on now might be very different man they
[ __ ] plant sunflowers and fight over
butter you know what I will say this
though the couples that I realize were
the most [ __ ] up were the ones that
always verbally said out loud that they
never fight that that everything is
perfectly fine they verbally had to tell
people that they're perfect and you can
see right through all their [ __ ]
it's when the wife does the fake smile
and the fourth yeah she's like clenching
her jaw yeah a key to a successful
relationship is a bitter faced wife in
an angry husband that's how you know
that's how you know it's it's real you
an old couple like shut up Muriel a mole
will you yeah I'm gonna show you this
[ __ ] woman I hate her
yeah it took out Bundy and pig Bundy
relationship yeah I like the fights in
my house holes it was real right your
mom runs well runs away
she was intense she hides behind what
garbage can I was Canada [ __ ] was tight
dude I miss those days my mom your dad
abused her no no I want just runs away
for no [ __ ] reason outside the
neighborhood play peekaboo yeah she's a
weird lady dude my dad - he'd always
days out he was gonna divorce her and he
was like imma find you a new mommy my
dad did I [ __ ] it like 28
you need a new mommy sounds very curry
yeah very Korea your house it was
violent yeah my dad dude he was scary he
like not my mom's tooth out to like my
thirties at the dinner table Gilbert he
looking Mike Tyson I don't know but I
remember she had a fake tooth put in or
something yeah no I think my brother
someone told ya he was there you know
yeah you didn't know I go no I didn't
know that Dad doctor - yeah well Koreans
are violent the Korean way is like to
beat the [ __ ] out of her and then
replace it with beautiful plastic
surgery in person you see yeah in in
that kind of household your rite of
passage is when you fist fight with your
dad that's what happened with my brother
my dad's when you get respect from your
dad and my brother did that I didn't get
that chance dude it was so trippy to
watch it like it was like an outer-body
experience yeah like I opened the door
and they're doing like like Jaime the
tiny monkey me [ __ ] hug feels like
literally watching kung fu' oh [ __ ] I
was like and I closed it and like my
adrenaline was gonna cut you jump in to
help I go Bob's becoming a man cuz he
would back him up my dela back him up
because my daddy's the box little guy
way with the fly way I don't know
yeah the little little and method over
quickly the 115-pound boot ban tabloids
doing that and then he like back him up
to the garage door my brother back my
dad up oh he started going back you know
doing his knees and you know to me
because my brother wrestled too so he's
doing that shoe that's when I donned on
me like like what you said I was like oh
[ __ ] this is like his right a passive no
no I was I was like going to church
camping who I who won the fight it was a
draw to me like what I saw was a draw
dude you know it was a dry bet you she
got your dad's respect though I think so
yeah I beat his ass that hard anymore
you did get his respect see but do
Korean you know you don't want to wake
them up when they're not taking a nap or
anyone or you still want to touch him
yeah the Vietnamese rite of passage is
when your mom offers you Hennessy oh
that's cool definitely a lot better
didn't know that year your dad was
abusive going to a deathmatch with your
dad yeah we got it easy we're good yeah
I hope you guys enjoy this video for
more please subscribe to our Channel and
you can check out the last video right
here
[Music]
[Music]